[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce magazine football en coupe de
france versailles se qualifie pour les
32e de finale de l'épreuve en gagnant
1-0 sur sa pelouse contre poissy le
résumé du match dans ce magazine tennis
un tournoi handisport était organisée
pendant trois jours par le comité d i
mean de tennis implantée à feucherolles
la championne de france yvelinoise
pauline déroulède étaient présentes sur
ce rendez vous pour préparer les jeux
olympiques de 2024
rugby coup de projecteur aujourd'hui sur
le plaisir rugby club le club fait
partie des meilleures formations en ile
de france et son équipe senior évolue en
fédérale 2 ce sera notre module
découverte l'actualité sportive c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence tout de suite par du
football et le 8e tour de la coupe de
france tout les yvelines ont scruté avec
attention ce derby à rarissime à ce
niveau de la compétition versailles
recevait poissy ce dimanche un match
équilibré qui s'est finalement soldée
par une qualification de versailles le
résumé du match des images de nicolas
landry un derby blinois sulfureux au 8e
tour de la coupe de france versailles
recevait poissy ce dimanche 28 novembre
au stade mob auront après une entame de
match versailles est ponctuée par
quelques occasions voici se reprend et
les joueurs pissier qui poussent pour
marquer mais n'arrive pas à concrétiser
leur offensive les équipes se séparent
sur un score nul et vierge à la pause 0
à 0 en première mi temps
c'était plutôt le mutant à notre
avantage en début de match on a mis un
peu de temps à entrer dans le match et
ensuite plus tôt le plutôt misé un autre
avantage dans la conservation du ballon
dans l'utilisation on va dire que sur
les dix premières minutes on a été très
bien en place discipline et on a
récupéré des ballons on qu'on a mal
exploité on n'a pas assez utilisé cette
profondeur
voici a repris un peu plus la maîtrise
du ballon un homme gardien fait une
parade sur la première mi temps au
retour des vestiaires les deux équipes
qui évoluent dans la même poule en
nationale 2 continue de se neutraliser
le tournant du match intervient à la 75e
minute christopher iba y marque sur
cette action à 10.6 poussé croit revenir
au score mais le but est refusé pour
hors jeu pour ce il obtiendra pas de
penalty sur cette dernière action versé
se qualifie pour les 32e de finale de
l'épreuve près satisfait une grosse
rencontre où on s'est tous donné que ce
soit les joueurs titulaires et ceux qui
sont rentrés on a tout donné et on a le
résultat final donc ça fait plaisir
frustrant parce que
versailles n'a aucune situation
6 buts qui le cette manière pour pouvoir
passer faut être efficace aujourd'hui on
n'a pas été comme bien souvent
d'ailleurs
si tu penses à qu'on ressent souvent des
matches comme ça frustre f le tirage au
sort aura lieu ce lundi 29 novembre avec
un objectif en tête pour les versailles
et aller le plus loin possible peu
importe l'adversaire et pourquoi pas une
équipe de ligue 1
dans l'autre enfant qui concernait à
clubs du département château ne
continuera malheureusement pas l'
aventure en coupe de france les
yvelinois qui évoluerait rhin se sont
fait éliminer par chartres une équipe de
nationale 2 au bout du suspense les
hommes de jean pierre papin l'ont
emporté 5 buts à 4 ce parcours en coupe
de france restera l'une des plus belles
épopées de chatou dans la compétition il
y avait également du handball ce
week-end en nationale 3 les clubs dits
vinoy n'ont pas brillé plaisir s'est
largement inclinée sur le teint de
loudéac 38 à 30 dans son côté où le
vésinet carrière perd 24 à 21
l'extérieur face à bois colombes au
classement plaisir les clés 9e sur 12 et
où ils le vésinet carrière et à
troisième en rugby chats ont joué ce
week-end pour le compte de la 7ème
journée de nationale 3 le mls gp s'est
brillamment imposé sur le teint de
petit-couronne 31,6 de son côté versé
est toujours invaincu grâce à une
victoire 24 à 17 sur le terrain de caen
enfin où il gagne 43 à 23 sur le teint
de cergy pontoise au classement verset
est toujours leader devant maisons
laffitte et mouiller les trois clubs
l'illinois sont donc sur le podium en
basket la ligue nationale a dévoilé ce
vendredi la liste des 20 joueurs
sélectionnés pour le all star game
français le 29 décembre prochain on
retrouvera sur le parquet de l'accord
hôtel arena en illinois le prodige
victor webb anyama été retenu pour
participer à l'événement elle sera
remplaçant avec l'équipe de france face
à l'équipe des étrangers le joueur de
l'asvel passait par le chesnay
versailles est à 17 ans l'une des plus
grandes promesses du basket français
avec ses 2 mètres 19 il attire tous les
regards des scouts de la nba on va
maintenant prendre la direction de
rambouillet grégory moyenne était jeudi
dernier à dans la commune le sportif
handisport un marathonien hémiplégique a
parcouru environ 600 km du 14 au 27
novembre pour sensibiliser les autorités
le grand public sur les droits liés au
handicap dans le monde by les parties de
sa vie de bordeaux pour rejoindre
l'elysée à paris en parcourant 40 km par
jour jeudi dernier à rambouillet le
trentenaire est venu échanger sur les
objectifs de ce projet avant de prendre
la direction de paris en tennis un
tournoi international de tennis fauteuil
s'est déroulée sur les courts du comité
des yvelines implantée à feucherolles au
programme plusieurs matchs 2 haut niveau
avec des champions français comme
pauline déroulède et anthony un bouc les
deux sportifs qui vise les jeux à
paralympiques en 2024 à paris des images
de nicolas dont brice
le tennis fauteuil à l'honneur à
feucherolles le comité des yvelines
organise un tournoi sur trois jours du
26 au 28 novembre avec au programme des
matches entre 16 des meilleurs joueurs
français une première pour un comité de
tennis nous avions un projet fort au
niveau du tennis fauteuil sur le comité
et c'était une façon de consolider
justement ce projet et puis de donner
une image un haut niveau du tennis
fauteuil pour attirer justement
davantage nous participons à ce niveau
là le comité les i mean compte à ce jour
trois sportifs intégré la cellule au
niveau mise en place par la structure
pour préparer les sportifs aux
compétitions internationales et aux jeux
paralympiques de 2024 on retrouve
notamment pauline déroulé de la
championne de france 2021 participer à
cette compétition j'étais ravi de jouer
ici voilà c'est mon lieu d'entraînement
le comité des yvelines donc c'est un peu
la maison j'ai pas fait
j'ai pas joué comme je voulais chez
voilà j'ai un nouveau fauteuil et c'est
vrai que je prenais encore mes marques
et puis voilà un peu fatigué de la
saison mais je suis content d'avoir
remporté la troisième place pour honorer
un podium pour pour mon comité la
sportive seules féminines présentes ce
jour là finalement terminé à la
troisième place de cette édition c'est
un très bon niveau voilà c'est des
garçons qui savent jouer au tennis qui
ont l'habitude l'expérience des tournois
voilà moi ça me permet de me confronter
à un très bon niveau voilà ça me fait ça
me fait bien jouer après il ya des
petits détails qui joue au mental
parfois une nouvelle édition de ce
tournoi seront organisées l'année
prochaine dans les yvelines à l'avenir
le comité des yvelines espèrent pouvoir
recevoir des sportifs internationaux sur
ces terrains
toujours en tennis libinois arthur
rinderknecht à jouer ce week-end en
coupe davis avec l'équipe de france ce
bilan mitigé le joueur de 26 ans a perdu
en simple face à cameron nouri 12e
mondial 6-2 7-6 mais il a remporté le
double avec nicolas mahut 6 1 6 4 face à
la grande bretagne mais les bleus sont
éliminés de la compétition et a lancé
après son tournoi vouloir garder le
positif et surtout en mémoire sa
première victoire dans la compétition
arthur rinderknecht le saint germanois
qui est le beau fils de patrick ottawa
le conseiller sportif territorial du
comité à daisy ligne de tennis patrick
ottawa il nous donne son avis sur la
saison d'arthur rien à cacher ses
performances à la coupe davis un joueur
qu'il a également coaché c'est notre
interview de passe
[Applaudissements]
j'ai évidemment regardé son match de
simple et son match de double c'est une
vraie fierté pour nous parce qu'en fait
il a eu un comportement exemplaire il a
deux balles de set au second j'aurais
bien aimé voir un troisième saut aurait
pu basculer
il a été très combatif très vaillants
très concentré très performant en double
et on va dire que c'est c'était une
journée de premiere première sélection
en équipe de france première fois numéro
un de l'équipe le première défaite
première défaite en coupe davis première
victoire mais un bilan super positif et
je pense que ça va l'aider encore à
passer un cap
pour bien connaître arthur depuis
maintenant assez longtemps et c'est
quelqu'un qui adore le collectif il a
commencé quand il était plus jeune par
beaucoup joué au foot et puis il a tout
il n'a jamais raté un match par équipe
c'est quelque chose qu'ils adorent ils
adorent partager et je pense que c'est
aussi une des raisons pour lesquelles il
ya aussi vite progresser
si on doit faire un bilan de la saison
d' art urbain il passe en deux ans de la
365e place à la 58e c'est assez
exceptionnel c'est un des joueurs qui a
gagné le plus de matches sur le circuit
professionnel cette année
c'est un bilan très positif et j'espère
qu'il va continuer sur cette lancée
arthur sait pas que c'est quelqu'un qui
digérera à mon avis très bien et très
vite il ya des objectifs de progrès qui
vont déboucher sur des objectifs de
résultat donc je suis absolument pas
inquiet il ira au bout de ce qui peut
faire et je pense qu'il n'a pas encore
atteint ce justement ce bout là comme
chaque mois le point sur les jeux
olympiques de 2024 avec notre
journaliste grégory canale qui nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau bonsoir et youri
pour michael alors dans
970 jours paris accueillera cgo et pour
la première fois aussi dans son histoire
les jeux paralympiques d'été c'est au
programme du 28 août au 8 septembre 2024
et dans ce cadre un projet unique au
monde dédié aux handisports va voir le
jour aux mureaux elie spc l'institut en
santé parra sport connectés sera
implanté sur le site de belleville au
mur ouverture prévue en 2024 au moment
même des jeux olympiques et des jeux
paralympiques de paris son ambition
associés recherche formation et aide à
la pratique du sport pour les personnes
en situation de handicap le dossier est
porté notamment par le professeur
françois jeunes est chef de service à
l'hôpital raymond-poincaré de garches
où le projet est en test actuellement
professeur à l'université versailles
saint quentin il était le responsable de
la délégation médicale paralympique à
tokyo 2020 on s'est rendu compte que les
personnes en situation de handicap avait
des difficultés pour se mettre au sport
et à l'activité physique et qu'il
fallait les aider qu'il fallait que la
santé qui est souvent la porte d'entrée
à la pratique du sport par le certificat
d'aptitude la réserve de pratique et
bien s'emparent de ce sujet et aide
toute cette population a débuté
l'activité physique et le sport alors si
je vous suis bien grégory l'institut en
santé par un sport connectés ce sera en
quelque sorte à l'insep du handisport ça
s'en rapproche grandement michael tout
comme l'institut national du sport de
l'expertisé et de la performance
il y as pc détectera les talents
accompagnera les sportifs de haut niveau
en assurant notamment un suivi médical
il sera également un centre de référence
de la classification des athlètes parra
sportifs en france et pour les
compétitions internationales mais on
parle plutôt ici 17 pour tous cas c'est
yes pc s'adressera à toutes les
personnes en situation de handicap trois
volets le constituent santé d'abord avec
le suivi et médical d'environ 5000
personnes ce qui représente 16 mille
consultations par an un axe formation
avec l'objectif de former 250
professionnels aujourd'hui il ya un vrai
manque sur la question du para sports et
enfin la recherche qu'elle soit
physiologique c'est à dire directement
sur le corps humain ou même
technologique en réunissant compétences
et moyens publics et privés l'idée de se
retrouver autour de ses pratiquants et
de les aider à pratiquer de les suivre
médicalement on a pas de recommandations
de suivi pour ces personnes qui
pratiquent du sport et c'est de voir
comment aller jusqu'à la pratique du
sport le plus longtemps possible dans le
bien vieillir des personnes en situation
de handicap et puis on sait aussi que le
sport est pathogène il peut abîmer les
épaules il peut et donc ne pas induire
un sur handicap à ces personnes qui vont
vivre longtemps et qui risque de perte
de l'autonomie s'il se blesse il ya une
dimension formations jouent les dix
formations des professionnels de santé
bien évidemment avec un essaimage
territorial le plus le plus large
possible
et puis de la recherche physiologique
est essentiellement technologique on
s'en est rendu compte avec le co vide il
faut commencer par sortir de chez soi
pour faire du sport il faut se déplacer
donc c'est les fauteuils roulants les
aides techniques les exosquelettes les
nouvelles toutes les nouvelles modalités
de déplacement il n'est pas anodin que
ce projet a chiffré à 30 me on d'euros
dont 20 millions par le département des
yvelines financés directement par le
département s'installe sur le site de
belleville un campus de formation aux
métiers de la santé des services à la
personne et de l'autonomie et doit s'y
implanter avec deux mille étudiants ont
aussi à quelques mètres du campus des
mureaux qui accueille chaque année le
salon autonomie dédié à l'innovation au
service de l'autonomie la finalité c'est
d'associer toutes ces synergies
territoriales pour devenir une référence
mondiale en la matière l'institut en
santé parra sport connecter à d'ailleurs
reçu le label héritage paris 2024 cas il
participera au développement des
populations de façon durable et ce même
après les jeux olympiques merci et
grégory pour toutes ces précisions vous
retrouvera le mois prochain pour votre
chronique sur les jeux olympiques de
2024 remet maintenant prendre la
direction du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le président
de la fédération française pascal grizot
et brigitte henriques présidente du
cnosf ont présenté vendredi dernier une
nouvelle version de mon carnet de golf
le livre pédagogique mais dit
multidisciplinaire qui avait rencontré
un grand succès auprès des scolaires
dans le cadre de l'accueil de la ryder
cup en 2018 à saint quentin en yvelines
cette fois ci le carnet sera centré sur
les valeurs de l'olympisme et des jeux
olympiques de 2024 pour illustrer les
épreuves de golf qui seront organisées
au golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines le livret devrait être diffusé
à plus de 3000 classe sur tout le
territoire pour 90 mille élèves de cm1
cm2 et 6e en passe maintenant à notre
coup de projecteur de la semaine
aujourd'hui tv 78 est allé du côté du
plaisir rugby club l'une des meilleures
structures en ile de france avec une
équipe en fédérale 2 à regarder
[Applaudissements]
ce soir le sol au rugby-club de plaisir
une structure qui compte 430 adhérents à
une équipe en fédérale 2 à ces partis
alors tiré l'amendé quand le club at il
été créé bonjour ma le club a été créé
en 1969 sous l'appellation plaisir rugby
club met en pratique est déjà le rugby
en 1961 au sein du club omnisports de la
ville de plaisir et c'est un club
important maintenant aujourd'hui au sein
de la ville de plaisir oui moi je pense
que c'est le plus gros club au niveau du
sport collectif c'est 430 licence
maintenant au jour d'aujourd'hui où les
revenus bien largement au dessus des
jauges qu'on avait avant le coc ide et
puis donc 2 l'activité poursuit bien sûr
toutes les catégories de personnes les
filles et quel est l'esprit du club de
plaisir c'est avant tout un public
familial où vous cherchez la performance
on a les deux niveaux il ya de
l'activité compétition ce nous on a
toujours été dans la compétition mais on
a aussi tout ce qui est ludique avec le
tout le rugby sans contact le loisir
également une section ce qui permet
d'avoir tout le monde trouve son bonheur
je dirai au sein du club compétition ou
loisir
l'objectif c'est d'aller le plus haut
possible
est ce que ce club mérite d'aller encore
un peu plus haut actuellement on est je
dirais pas très loin de la qualification
c'est les six premiers qui se qualifie
c'est ce qui est l'objectif là pour la
saison sachant que avec la réforme un
peu de la fédération française de rugby
avec les créations de national en
nationale 2 la fédérale 1 donc ce sera
peut-être plus facilement accessibles
sachant que logiquement 24 clubs vont
monter cette année en fédérale 1
au fur et à mesure de l'histoire du club
le la structure seniors a toujours été
le plus haut possible au classement
bon on est monté progressivement moi je
suis arrivé en seniors à 18 19 ans on
était en honneur on est on a fait la
montée en 3e division à l'époque donc ça
date mais bon ça toujours été sonné
montant d une vision aussi à l'ancienne
formule on a je dirais toujours été
[Musique]
entre la deuxième lettre e division les
jus descendu une fois pendant deux
saisons sur l'honneur ça ça doit faire
une vingtaine d'années pour parler de la
structure sportive et de cette équipe
qui est actuellement en fédérale 2 nous
allons justement rencontré sébastien en
rang cali
[Musique]
maintenant sur le terrain mais côté
sébastien ans cali qui est directeur
sportif du club de plaisir est également
manager général des seniors alors
sébastien on va tout d'abord commencer
par ses équipes seniors qui évoluent en
fédérale 2 comment elle se comporte
cette année
installés ont fait un parcours qui est
vraiment très intéressant puisque pour
la première fois au bout de neuf matchs
on se retrouve dans les qualifiables
donc 6e ex-aequo avec courbevoie chose
qui n'était jamais arrivé à ce niveau là
on a loupé quelques points sur les
premiers matches donc on aurait pu être
encore mieux mais c'est déjà très bien
après deux années où on devait déjà
validé notre travail et puis à cause du
coup vite comme tout le monde
malheureusement ça s'est pas fait donc
on est très très content cette année de
pouvoir effectivement être à cette place
à ce moment là et à ce que le manager
roncalli et est heureux justement depuis
le début de la saison avec ce groupe
ouais je suis très très heureux je suis
très très heureux c'est dans la
continuité des quatre premières années
tout se passe vraiment très bien et les
garçons évoluent dans le bon sens soit
c'est quoi le plus grand rêve quand on
est manager et directeur sportif d'un
club comme plaisir
par rapport à ma mission de manager
basse est arrivé à jouer la
qualification cette année voilà c'est
notre objectif après sur le club j'ai
travaillé sur beaucoup de choses là est
passé je suis très content de
l'évolution qui se passe actuellement
sur le club et sur quoi vous avez
travaillé justement à ces vestiaires
rockalies alors je crois savoir que les
jeunes c'est un petit peu votre
cheval de bataille si je peux dire oui
complètement moi je milite pour
effectivement renforcer notre formation
parce que si on a une formation de
qualité tout le reste en découle et
après donc on a travaillé sur un centre
d'entraînement qui s'est ouvert cette
année qui fonctionne plutôt très bien
j'ai travaillé aussi en parallèle sur
l'école de rugby donc sur le fait
d'aller chercher une labellisation une
troisième étoile sur notre labellisation
et déjà deux étoiles ce qui est déjà
très bien mais là on est devrait obtenir
notre troisième étoile cette année
puisque on avait notamment un critère
qui nous faisait de défaut c'était les
féminines là aujourd'hui de nos moins de
6 aux cadettes donc au moins 19 on a des
filles dans toutes les catégories on a
un groupe d chez les moins de 15 de 20
filles donc on est vraiment dans le bon
sens et on a ouvert une équipe senior
féminine qui fonctionne plutôt très bien
en entente avec vélizy pour une première
année donc je suis vraiment très
satisfait du travail réalisé mais
l'essence du club on l'a compris c'est
avant tout la formation de fabriquer des
des futurs joueurs peut-être pour la
fédérale 2 mais également pour le plus
haut niveau peut être des fois ah oui
bien sûr tout à fait là on a déjà
trois garçons qui sont partis au plus
haut niveau fédéral une depuis quatre
ans qu'on a fait évoluer dont la garçon
qui était arrivé de série et puis en
deux ans voilà ils se retrouveront
fédéral une une très belle progression
au delà bien sûr de développer le club
de réaliser des performances en fédérale
2 notre première mission c'est de former
des mecs pour aller plus haut
effectivement si on a ça on a gagné
quand les directeurs sportifs ça fait
quoi justement de voir un joueur qui
évolue aussi au c'est un plaisir c'est
vraiment un grand plaisir c'est une
validation de notre travail par rapport
à ça d'ailleurs je remercie tous les
gens qui s'impliquent au club et
notamment tous nos bénévoles tous nos
éducateurs tous nos entraîneurs voilà on
a fait tous ensemble un beau travail
voilà ça paye effectivement cette année
est-ce qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
travail à faire pour que le club
grandissante en plus c'est sur ces
prochaines saisons ah oui bien sûr oui
il faut chaud arrivé à pérenniser ce
qu'on a entrepris
on a renforcé tous nos stages dans les
catégories mais voilà il faut rester
vigilant moi je continue aussi également
d'accompagner ceux qui passent leur
brevet actuellement
et notre but c'est effectivement d'avoir
la formation la plus performante
possible c'est vraiment la kz2 priorité
peut-être pour quand on est directeur
sportif d'un club comme plaisir
complètement je pense que c'est vraiment
la priorité d'un club le fait d'avoir
une formation de qualité
et assez en nombre pour pouvoir voilà
encadrer tout ce monde encore une fois
avec l'esprit de faire le meilleur
travail possible terne où on le voit ils
sont en train de s'entraîner durement
pour pour les prochains matchs en
fédérale 2 est ce qu'il ya des joueurs
sur lesquels vous vous appuyer pour les
prochaines rencontres oui bien sûr dans
le groupe il ya plusieurs leaders
effectivement et bien sûr notamment mon
capitaine françois le vilain que je
connais depuis très longtemps moi je
suis un ancien joueur du club aussi on a
eu la chance de jouer quelques instants
avant et puis bah maintenant qu'on se
retrouve quelques années après on a une
vraie complicité way françois dumoulin
on va le rencontrer a sur le terrain
je suis donc à côté de deux enfants du
club françois le vilain à hugo
taillandier alors françois les villans
ont parlé de toi justement avant avec
sébastien roch ali tu es là depuis 19 20
ans c'est ça ouais ça doit être ça la
fidh et le fidèle au club et aux copains
ici donc voilà je suis j'habite plaisir
et c'est mon club de toujours donc voilà
c'est ça ça doit faire un
pas mal d'années ouais je les compte
plus qu'est ce qui fait que tu reste
justement un plaisir pour moi c'est cet
esprit un peu justement à meetic est
très très fort club très familial moi je
suis arrivé tard dans le rugby j'avais
16 ans et c'est vrai que je vais dans un
sport individuel avant et j'ai trouvé
ici un état d'esprit incroyable le sport
comme à
adopter et plus particulièrement le
rugby ici et j'ai jamais eu envie de
partir quoi c'est quoi c'est une bande
de potes on peut le dire ici à plaisir
ouais une bande de potes et puis aussi a
eu ce côté aussi compétition qui
rentrait vraiment en compte
j'ai toujours été et compétiteur et
c'est ce que j'ai trouvé ici en venant
venant à plaisir est à la fois il ya la
convivialité via le sport et la
compétition qu'elle a tout son sens et
ont je pense qu'on le prouve à nous
après année et c'est pour ça que j'ai
jamais eu envie de partir tout
simplement à lorgues où taillandier toi
c'est un petit peu la même chose alors
toi tu es au club par contre depuis 17
ans c'est ça ouais depuis sept ans j'ai
commencé le rugby très tôt en
minipoussins et puis j'ai grandi ici au
club comme disait fassois et à l'esprit
de famille c'est ça qui nous souder qui
permet aujourd'hui d'être à notre niveau
et voilà une bonne bande de potes et ça
c'est vraiment hyper après ça quand on
fait un sport qu'on aime si j'ai bien
compris tu as fait toutes ses classes en
fait ici à un plaisir passe à 'aa' mini
poussins poussins et puis toutes les
catégories jusqu'en juniors et voilà
aujourd'hui la fédérale 2 c'est niveau
que que le club a et on est très très
fier et très content et je pense que
même on peut chercher un peu plus un peu
plus haut et on est on est sur une bonne
route c'est un petit peu un rêve je sais
pas pour
un jeune du club de cet habit de plaisir
à commencer rugby ici à 7 ans à plaisir
ce que c'est un peu un rêve d'accéder à
aux seniors un jour et à la fédérale 2 e
oui c'est vrai surtout que ma première
année senior je suis arrivé dans le club
est monté directement en fédérale 2 et
puis oui c'est un très bon niveau on s'y
plaît voilà on veut toujours aussi plus
parce que voilà l'état d'esprit c'est la
compet et je pense qu'encore une fois on
peut aller chercher un le haut de
tableau et voir un peu plus avec toutes
les infrastructures qu'on a donc ouais
c'est c'est un rêve et puis le rêve ce
serait de jouer avec mon petit frère qui
lui aussi en les petites catégories
voilà ça sera un vrai rêve quand je joue
avec lui on lui souhaite en tout cas
comment tu évalues ce groupe on l'a dit
c'est une bande de une bande de potes
des amis mais c'est avant tout un esprit
compétitif a ici un plaisir on le voit
derrière nous on s'entraîne durement ici
à un plaisir ouais on s'entraîne
durement après voilà nous joueurs on
veut encore plus d'intensité toujours
toujours plus après il faut faire avec
ce qu'on a aussi les présences faut
composer aussi avec avec les joueurs qui
ont un boulot qui finissent un peu plus
tard mais c'est vrai que c'est très
plaisant vous êtes un club de haut
niveau mais également avec un budget qui
pas forcément énorme ici à plaisir vous
bataillez contre des équipes qui ont
deux voire trois fois plus de budget que
vous et finalement vous en sortez pas si
mal ouais bah c'est ça aussi pour venir
sur la question tu me posait tout à
l'heure c'est aussi ce qui fait notre
fierté c'est d'être d'être ce qu'on ait
aujourd'hui d'avoir réussi à atteindre
ce niveau de perdurer à ce niveau
je crois que c'est la cinquième saison
qu'on fait en fédérale 2 et c'est une
très très grande fierté personnellement
par alan est aussi collectivement
d'exister à ce niveau avec ceux avec ce
budget ce club familial comme usé de
talent r c'est vrai que on rencontre des
équipes tous les week-ends avec des très
gros budget le double triple voire si ce
n'est plus par rapport à notre budget
des joueurs qui sont quasiment
professionnels qui sont rémunérés avec
avec des salaires tous les mois et c'est
vrai que comme le disait hugo nous on
travaille tous
voilà on a tous des bouleaux beaucoup
d'étudiants et voilà il ce club nous
offre autre chose que de l'argent et
c'est vrai que c'est vraiment flatteur
essais on est tous fiers d'évoluer à ce
niveau là et de et d'exister alors que
tous les week-ends c'est un peu
compliqué mais je pense que la saison
qu'on fait cette année on trouve que bah
y'a pas que le budget qui est qui compte
quoi qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter
à tous les deux pour cette saison
déjà de la réussite et continuer en fait
sur cette lancée et puis toujours garder
cet état d'esprit qui est juste
incroyable
de la réussite et puis la qualif surtout
la qualif je pense que c'est françois
velle va le dire mais c'est lui le
capitaine celica le dernier mot
capitaine non oui c'est sûr que bon ben
voila depuis depuis plusieurs années à
ce niveau là on a tous fait les
premières années pour se maintenir là
maintenant c'est vrai que depuis que
sébastien a pris
le groupe on a des objectifs toujours
plus haut et c'est vrai que le maintien
est derrière nous maintenant il faut
viser la qualification et ça serait
vraiment un bonheur pour moi qui suis
peut-être sur mes dernières années de
vivre de vivre ces moments là donc oui
c'est évident que cette année il faut
pas se le cacher on aimerait aimerait
aller chercher une qualification parce
que je vous dis je vous des phases
finales c'est s'aider saveur très
particulière ça n'a pas de prix et voilà
vivre ça ça serait juste ce serait juste
énorme quoi et avec les supporters on
vous le souhaite en tout cas bon courage
pour la suite de la saison et surtout
beaucoup de victoires ici un plaisir une
équipe en fédérale 2 et peut-être une
équipe en fédérale une dans les
prochaines années en attendant à l'essai
s'entraider
je vous rassure pas de blessures de mon
côté c'est la fin de cette émission à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]